Als Sie in dieser Materialienbewegung kommen, von mascara auf anspr promised.
Sie können aus
zwölf
Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Das ist kein super Cloud-Native-Agile-GitOps-Solutions-Excellence-Chief-Engineer-Officer-for-DevOps-Big-Brain-Scrum.
Ja ja, ucwa genau, ucwa api, ich erinnere mich noch dunkel dran, genau, richtig monarch
es der kram ach ich will es jetzt eigentlich ganz ehrlich ich will ich will mich damit
einschalten es ist aber es ist wirklich richtig richtig eklig gewesen also leute ich ich versuche
euch mal kurz zu erklären was wir heute vor haben und zwar ich habe ja aktuell bei hetzer
vier server laufen drei backend server und ein frontend mit anwendung drauf also sprich
das was ihr beim preischamp seht aber wie gesagt wir programmieren heute nichts am preischamp
oder so und ich habe mir jetzt überlegt ok so wirklich glücklich bin ich mit der lösung
nicht wie ich das gerade mache mit dem mit dem neu aufbauen und wir machen heute den
big brain cloud native excellence of github solution scrum kann man safe lösungs ansatz
und als erstes machen wir mal einen stand up leute also jeder der vom rechner sitzt ist
definitiv nicht agil von euch das muss das muss ich euch jetzt wiederholen das noch mal
also das müssen wir erstmals wir müssen jetzt erst mal stand up machen und user stories definieren
sonst können wir überhaupt nicht anfangen damit also so ist so ist so wie im echten
leb ok ich stehe auch nicht wirklich auf leute also wer jetzt aufgestanden ist hut ab aber
auch ich habe ich habe subs übersehen war mal kurz easy killers 16 monate schon am start
massive hyper subscription wer ist denn überhaupt alles am start ich mach das mal wieder lost
ich lese jetzt auch erst mal drei stunden einfach die anwesenheit vor und dann kackt
wahrscheinlich twitch wieder ab den hamann am start start ihr ist fehler serious maxis
auch da lehn art kyoko und senpi clocks hd real rennachs world x nattachs sebiks overlay
ich hoffe ich lese nicht doppelt nicht doppelt vor jetzt muss ich ja juniken bei mir im kopf
farkts stripes 007 herz 391.000.000 69 quinn hier rotex warty i am boy 08 max 07 easy killer
kap cobalt kap cobalt der captain cobalt ist am start leute da kann captain wie gibts
da captain marvel und so einpacken wenn captain cobalt kommt wie nur von captain metal getoppt
so dann haben wir noch ein notiz block changer bei striker ein bei strike geisi choose my
name x fatal ist auch am start matrix hd rindoor prot kill fill der bronco so leute ich glaube
ich habe kein doppelt vorgelesen habe ich habe ich ordentlich habe ich habe ich ordentlich
junikt im kopf ja das passt also trotz ich habe ich habe ich noch mehr subs übersehen
moment ich bin verwirrt warte mal hier ist fehler siehmona dankeschön für den sub massive
big brain subscription ja und denkt leute leute selbstverständlich machen wir für alles
auch ein hierer ticket auf oder sorry leute ein natürlich ein jaira ticket was allerdings
auch passend verknüpft sein muss weil einfach tickets erstellt geht nicht ja da müssen die
passenden stakeholder informiert sein und natürlich auch alle service und produkt manager mit ins
boot geholt werden aber chat ich sehe schon ihr habt die richtige hands on mentalität
das magisch das magisch chat deswegen seid ihr auch der das gibt es nur bei mir wenn es
nicht ein papp für den preis chat machen ja unbedingt und struktur kramm struktur kramm
auch noch wie lange ist der sprint vier wochen für vier wochen sprinten einfach jetzt mal
los wir haben gestern bei der wo davon umfrage gelernt es ist gar nicht so wild dass wenn
man das man von anfang an in den projekten plan hat das kann sich auch im laufe der zeit
entwickeln neue apex season auch habe ich null verfolgt soll ich hoffe ich habe keine
subs übersehen also nur melde ja kamen die uml ist nicht egal genug mache ich nicht ich
mache nur agile best practices und da gehört uml nicht dazu bin gerade dabei mein projekt
für die abschlussprüfung äh was man ein giant giant e viel dankeschön für den sub
was hat ein giant master geschrieben hier gigant nicht giant master hier bin gerade
dabei mein projekt für die abschlussprüfung zu planen was willst du machen erzählen schieß
los oh ja wichtig wichtig trello karte und kann ins kann bahn bahn muss natürlich auch
logisch ich habe xd xd xd vergessen hat auch nichts geschrieben bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo
ich vorgelesen habe hast du denn auch eine amazon aws cloud zertifizierung für dieses
ja nee aber ich habe mir äscher ich habe äscher schulungen gemacht aber keine zertifizierung
confluence ornee confluence sagt confluence kann man nicht cool aussprechen man hier kann
man auch weg zu gyra aussprechen aber ich ich ich wähle meine tools nicht danach aus
wie gut sie funktionieren sondern man sie cool aussprechen kann oder nicht ich meine es
ist ja kein grund dass ich dass ich ubuntu als jubanto auf dem surfer verwende sonst
könnte ich sonst könnte ich ja auch suze verwenden ja wobei ganz im ernst suze wird
im leben das fasse ich nicht an alter wie heißt denn sharepoint richtig ja leider sharepoint
deswegen sagt auch was geht mir der musik gerade ab a paper mario alles klar ok also
ich versuche ich mal grob zu erklären was ich heute vor hab also schreibe schreibe
mal etwas vor wenn du wenn du was zu deinem abschlussprojekt sagt das also ich über
sehe das heute ich bin gerade nicht aufnahmefähig für den chat kennst du eine alternative zu
discord on premise bei the way und premise für die nicht cloud native noobs bedeutet
bei sich selbst installiert also selbst hostet das nennt man heute nicht mehr installieren
oder hosten das nennt man on premise weil wir sind die coolen cloud native jungs da
ist das so ehrlich gesagt nee kenne ich nicht viele viele sagen matrix und so
was aber ich habe das noch nie verwendet ich weiß nicht ob das taugt
nein ich will keinen papp machen ich mache höchstens gleich mit euch zusammen
ein ischikawa diagramm während wir uns asmr maus sounds anhören
ubuntu die beste seite kenne ich das ist so ein zirkus das fand ich früher schon lustig
ja hast du schon gesehen dass jett prance was neues killer untouch space oder wie das heißt ja
aber ich weiß nicht was es ist ich komme ich kann ich kann überhaupt nicht dazu was ich heute machen
will chat also was ist denn jett prance spaces in spaces klingt klingt wie irgendwie teams teams ja
das ok das ist ein teams konkurrent ok scale das auch horizontal wie wir leute horizontal scaling
horizontal scale ist out wir scaling weder horizontal noch vertikal wir scaling diagonal
ich lasse mir das morgen patentieren ab dann wird nur noch diagonal gescaled serverless bei uns
serverless serverless ist noch viel zu viel wir haben infrastructure less läuft unser zeug
komplett in der cloud serverless infrastructure less codeless brainless was hast du gegen susi
ich finde es eklig zu benutzen der um und fragt ich will eine tk anlage von isdn zur
ip migration machen als abschlussprojekt denkst du die akzeptieren das ja wenn du es gut verkaufst
definitiv das könnte aber ein bisschen viel sein für wie viel sind das ab wie viel sind das 30
stunden abschlussprojekt das könnte ganz schön viel sein
was die schreibt wir benutzen auf der arbeit ich muss erstmal einblenden wir nutzen auf der arbeit
seit diesem jahr in in lux habe ich noch nie gehört kein blasen schimmer was das ist was
jetzt los browser in lux und das ist das schlechteste projekt management software
die ich jemals benutzt habe ich weiß nicht wer ich dachte die meiste als outlook plugin
ach du große scheiße ok das muss ich muss mal danach suchen kurz
das sieht schon cringe aus und werbevideo pains jem
das will man nicht benutzen das muss echt nicht sein das gantia kram ist das hier das
gantia kram ich hatte in meiner abschlussprüfung gantia kram drin leute es fand die irk richtig
geil gantia kram wisst ihr mit was ich das gantia kram gemacht habe damals mit emers
project das war das erste und einzige mal in meinem leben dass ich wirklich die big stonks
office tools verwendet habe und danach habe ich das nie wieder angefasst okay aber mein
beileid das sieht wirklich grausam aus das lean magazine das ist für die krasse management stonks
leute das sieht aus wie 2008 war was ein kack dass ich könnte wetten wo ob die ich könnte
wetten das ist so gelaufen irgendein typ von der verkaufsabteilung von von in logs war
am start weil der jemand kennt von eure management und die haben da quasi beim beim was weiß
ich beim gemeinsam tennis spielen oder so gesagt man könnte noch mal eine präsentation machen
und dann wurde das präsentiert und euer management hat gesagt alter so ein geiles tool das brauchen
wir und dann war es am start und es wurden nicht einmal die leute gefragt diese am ende
benutzen müssen könnte ich mir vorstellen also das würde mir zumindest bekannt vorkommen
also ich muss jetzt mal zeige ich hier mit dem chat durchkommen dass ich euch erklären
was wir heute machen und premise ist das beste scheiß auf der wie gesagt hosten installieren
selber betreiben ist ja komplett out vom namen her heute nennt man das alles und premise
und die richtig die richtig geilen cloud native big brain excellence leute die sagen on prem
weil sich das weil die damit quasi dann aussagen wollen sie haben diesen cloud jargon soll
schon so verinnerlicht dass sie gar nicht mehr normal reden können das heißt man also
wenn man noch on premise sagt oder sogar selbst hostet oder installiert oder auf eigenem server
ist das komplett komplett out die richtig coolen leute sagen nur noch on prem und wahrscheinlich
und wahrscheinlich dauert es nicht mehr lang dann gibt es dafür noch mal ein eigenes noch
mal ein eigenes richtig cooles cooles sonderwort was könnte man dafür nehmen für selbst für
selbst hosten ist man selbst host ist und on premise ist deutlich zu deutlich zu zu
verbreitet schon das braucht so richtig so richtig geilen irgendwas mit in house oder
so keine ahnung ich kann bin ich kann mir sowas nicht ich kann mir sowas nicht mehr
nicht ausdenken hab genau hab als abschlussprojekt thema ein smart home system in einem
besprecher das ist ein cooles thema das haben die bestimmt nicht oft es soll mit der autog
raumbuch verknüpfen also da kann ich okay das ja kann man verknüpfen kann man ja machen
ich meine da würde ich das nicht also selbst implementieren würde ich da nichts das geht
eindeutig über den rahmen raus aber da kann ich dir einen tipp zu geben du hast sicherlich
schon ein was wir moment ich dachte den buchungssystem für den besprechungsraum ein smart home system
in einem besprechen ok dass man was abgedreht ist aber ich kann dir trotzdem in den tipp
geben und zwar sag nicht du installierst da projekt x produkt xy sondern schreib in
dein projektantrag rein auswahl eines geeigneten smart wie auch immer diese software kategorie
heißt smart business meeting system und dann machst du und dann machst du so einen bewertungskatalog
und dein system was du eh schon haben willst gewinnt dann zufällig aber so musst du das
machen da steht die iacard drauf und dann nehmen die das auch an also du darfst auf keinen
fall reinschreiben ich nehme system xy installier das das ist zu zu low brain die iacard will
sehen dass du quasi die stonks kaufmann sachen machst du machst dann einfach ein auswahl
matrix und vielleicht machst du noch einen gantt diagramm dabei und dann bist du auf
der sicheren seite das ist jetzt kein witz das meine ich wirklich eins vorher habe ich
habe ich habe bis zu diesem zeitpunkt nur scheiße erzählt im stream aber das meine
ich ernst so das reicht jetzt auch genug sinnvolle sachen erzählt
so haben wir es hier wir gelten im komplett wie gesagt diagonal wird nur noch gescald
bei uns hier naja einfach wir brauchen einfach weitere dimensionen das kann ja nicht zu
viel verlangt sein oder wie gesagt hardwareless codeless infrastructureless brainless läuft
unser zeug das ist sogar richtig gut weil da brauchst du keine menschen mehr so sieht
es aus was wisst ihr was es für kosten spart wenn man brainless läuft multidimensional
scaling ja die griechen sind eh out wen hinter den griechen heute noch ja glaube ich du
musst das aber gut schreiben du musst das wie gesagt du musst du musst das gut verpacken
was ich zu meinem abschlussprojekt gemacht habe war auch nix großartiges ich habe einen
open vpn gebaut zwischen zwei rechnern habe das allerdings standort koppelung mittel
wie habe ich mein abschlussprojekt genannt habe schon wieder vergessen standort koppelung
auf layer 2 basis irgendwie so in der richtung habe ich telefonie standort koppelung irgendwas
in der richtung habe ich das genannt ich habe im prinzip einen vpn von rechner a zu rechner
b gehabt so das hatten wir doch schon gerade outlook ist bei uns richtig abartig
und bram genau was ist denn microsoft sccm ist das ist das code safe oder wie das heißt
so a system center configuration manager aha ne ne bloß nicht selbst programmieren also
meinte ich das auch nicht du darfst ihn aber nicht sagen was du verwenden willst du musst
ihn sagen du wählst software dafür aus und dann gewinnt halt die software die du benutzen
willst das ist ja nicht schwierig zusammenzufaken aber wichtig dass du den sagst ich ich führe
eine produkt auswahl durch das mögen die ja genau so so hieß das ich mein abschlussprojekt
hieß irgendwie was in der in dieser richtung ich glaube es war irgendwas mit standort koppelung
auf layer 2 basis irgendwas in der richtung ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher im prinzip
habe ich vpn installiert ok so jetzt kommen wir zum einigen cacquaint jetzt genug chat
jetzt ich ich gucke aber nebenbei immer noch chat wisst ihr ja also was wir machen ist
folgendes ich habe ja aktuell also die preis die preis champ infrastructure ja sieht aktuell
so aus ein frontend server mit aktuell 16 kern was bescheuert ist es wird runter gescaled
ich mache mal das was sein soll mit zwei oder drei kern dann gibt es drei ich nenne sie
mal nicht crawler crawler klingt zu negativ wirka wirka drei wirka server mit jeweils
drei cpu so das ist fetcher nein wirka wirka ist viel besser wirka kann alles sein also
aktuell aktuell sind vier sind sind vier kisten so und das ist aktuell alles bei hetzner
was ich in zukunft machen will ist und und cloud flair cloud flair davor so sieht das
kurz mein num block ist aus so sieht das aktuell aus so und was ich in zukunft vor hab ist das
frontend zu ovh zu packen wegen die haben ergeblich so richtig nice dedos protection
ich weiß nicht ob ich es gemerkt habe der preis champ wurde heute morgen gededost um
acht Uhr zwanzig für fünf minuten oder so und da hat sich aber danach wieder neu gestartet
überhaupt kein problem ging wieder wann kommt cast champ as a good idee champ as a service
excellent hast du abi oder real ich hoffe ich habe big brain das das reicht ich habe
einen realtest abschluss gemacht und dann habe ich eine ausbildung angefangen da hatte
man keinen bock mehr drauf das war stonks ausbildung deswegen habe ich auch die abneigung
entwickelt aber ich kann aus meiner ersten ausbildung immerhin die buchhalternase und
ich weiß dass man linear und dekretiv abschreiben kann das habe ich mir gemerkt ja nicht dass
ich noch wüsste was man wie genau aber das habe ich mir gemerkt mehr weiß ich nicht
mehr von der ganzen sache und dann hab ich meine ausbildung gemacht beim provider das
wird auch schon 2007 gewesen auf debate basis ok also so sieht es so sieht das aktuell aus
was ich in zukunft machen will ist folgendes welche weiterbildung nach der ausbildung
empfiehlt zu wenn jetzt ein arbeitgeber da nicht großartig wert drauf legt auf zertifikate
musste dann nicht unbedingt professionelle weiterbildung besuchen es ist einfach wichtig
dass du am bald bleibt was aktuelle technik angeht und das geht meiner meinung nach auch
nur wenn man sich privat dafür interessiert guck mal das ganze zeug was ich hier im stream
mache das mache ich aus zwei gründen zu 90 prozent weil es mich interessiert zu 5 prozent
weil ich es cool finde wenn dabei leute zugucken und man sich mit den austauschen kann dabei
und zu 5 prozent für so ungefähr bin ich nicht ganz sicher ob die prozentuale verhältnisse
ob das ob das stimmt aber so ungefähr ok also in zukunft in zukunft will ich das so
machen eigentlich ist scheißegal wir machen das jetzt einfach vergesst was ich wollte
also und ich habe es aktuell so ich kann es euch nicht zeigen weil dann müsste ich hier
reingehen und guck mal wie das heißt das kann ich jetzt dann aufmachen leute ich habe das
extra dran geschrieben sonst liege ich mir da alle ips wusste ich sein ja aber von der
idee her besteht das price champ backend quasi aus vier vier solcher server also aktuell
besteht aktuell bestand das price champ backend aus einem so einem server aber das war total
overkill und aktuell besteht aus vier solcher server sprich das kostet aktuell was denn
8,2 mal 4 ja google 24 euro 25 euro also vollkommen in ordnung mal 3 mal 4 also 33 euro und die
erste variante die ich hatte war 16 kerner plus 10 extra ips das heißt ich habe 60 euro
für den server bezahlt und nochmal ungefähr 12 euro obendrauf für die 10 festen ips oder
zusätzliche extra ips also sprich ich habe 72 euro bezahlt das war mir dann doch ein
bisschen teuer für was womit ich nichts verdiene im monat ja ok das sagt giant master das sagt
aber wichtig ist dass du dich für so sachen interessiert das meiste ganz ehrlich das meiste
habe ich privat gelernt ganz im ernst natürlich habe ich auch auf der arbeit recht viel mit
bekommen und das verfeinert irgendwo aber so wirklich die neuen sachen habe ich extra
meist privat gelernt weil es mich interessiert hat und wenn man das dann auf der arbeit einsetzen
kann ist natürlich gut dann sammelt man erfahrungen mit ich hätte ich hätte ich hätte nie damals
angefangen mit git lab und quasi sowas wie continuous integration continuous das hat
man die buzzwords damals auch gar nicht dafür gehabt und ich will mich privat dafür interessiert
ja genau choose my name das wird das muss ich auch noch erzählen dabei
genau das muss ich auch noch dazu erzählen und zwar die server sehen folgendermaßen
verknüpft aus zeige ich jetzt auch noch mal also das frontend mal krasse ascii art skills
public ip ne stimmt stimmt gar nicht cloud flair public ip dann kommt man auf das front
frontend darauf läuft also von da wird ausgeliefert des vgs frontend und darauf läuft auch dass
die dotnet core app so und dann gibt es dahinter drei drei wie habe ich genannt worker server
und die sind verbunden mit dem frontend über ein internes internes netz also so funktioniert
das wobei es eigentlich nur ein weg ist so so sieht das so sieht das aus so und was ich
jetzt gebastelt habe ist folgendes ich habe mir einen script gebaut womit ich diese server
wieder aufbauen kann aber das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht das habe ich ganz eklig zusammengewusstet
einfach dass es geht habe ich gestern gemacht so nicht gestern oder doch gestern war montag
ne ja einfach weil das 16 core server gesagt hat und teilweise schon ich bei manchen seiten
im cloud flair hängen geblieben bin deswegen habe ich mir gedacht erstens reduzieren wir
mal ein bisschen die crawling rate und ich habe auch die ip aufgeteilt dass nicht alles
geplacklistet wird so gehen wir mal kurz chat durch achso das kann für dich auch ein vorteil
sein was ich finde ich finde es immer komisch dass betriebe leute ausbilden um sie nicht
zu übernehmen aber das würde natürlich auch passen dazu wenn du gesagt hast du hast kaum
was gelernt und bist nur im service desk und macht tickets was im prinzip heißt die haben
wahrscheinlich jemand gesucht der billig ist und den mist macht ja
ich habe heute mal geguckt dass ich noch ein paar jobs raussuche für das nächste stellenanzeige
review habe ich gesehen peter wubbler wird auch gebannt aber mein nächsten linkedin fake
account werde ich ganz furchtbar big brain machen und zwar mache ich mir eine echte fake
telefonnummer irgendwo also gibt es ja gibt es ja genug services die das die das machen
ja und ich nehme irgendwie einen einer meiner domains ich habe ja mittlerweile genug domains
und machen wir da ein email postfach und das sieht wirklich null null fake aus wahrscheinlich
schaut hier gerade ein linkedin mod zu ja gut was was will er dann machen was will er
dann machen er weiß weder wie ich mich anmelde noch von welcher ip ich zugreife noch von
welchem browser noch wie mein name ist noch welche domain ich nehme das kann er nicht
er kennt außerdem ist es dem auch persönlich wahrscheinlich scheiß egal her her j punkt
e baited das ist ein geiler name so müsste ich mich echt nennen ja j punkt e baited
den ich als profilbild ich mache auch irgendwas seriöses ins profilbild ich ich nehme irgendwie
mann in anzug stockfoto jeremy e baited genau gut also weiter im text so sieht das aktuell
aus so sieht das aktuell aus das ist die preis jam infrastruktur und ich hätte es gerne
dass ich das automatisch ordentlich aufbauen kann deswegen habe ich mir folgendes überlegt
und das versuchen wir heute mal zu skripten ich mache erstens also das mal ich mache ich
mache ein neues ich mache erstmal ein neues git repo wo ich mir mal eine sinnvolle struktur
überlege für infrastructure files und für die apps und für den crawler und alles mögliches
aber gut das ist eine sache geht inne zu machen dauert zwei sekunden dann gucken wir skript
über hetsner cloud api zum server erstellen da weiß ich schon prinzipiell wie das funktioniert
da muss ich mir den api key generieren und da muss ich euch ausblenden weil sonst könnt
ihr bei mir ne terraform ist in dem fall nicht so gut das habe ich mir auch überlegt
ich habe es mir auch schon überlegt ob ich das ob ich nicht big brain cloud cloud native
cloud native agile github solution software excellence scrum kann man software verwenden
soll ich habe an terraform gedacht allerdings ich muss da ein paar sachen wirklich mit logik
skripten dahinter und kubernetes bringt mir absolut gar nichts in dem fall ich brauche
hier auch api's die wechseln das kann ich glaube ich schlecht in terraform machen oh
nee overwatch halte ich halte ich geistig geistig net aus das geht nicht leute unmöglich
ja so dann müssen wir gucken dass man das mit n simple aufbauen kann das geht ja schon
für das frontend so dass ich nur noch mit einem klick da man ganzen krams drauf deployen
kann so und also von der logik her muss das so sein das skript der legt in der muss eine
neuen server anlegen dann muss der auch gleich da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher wie es funktioniert
dann muss der auch das private netz atttach über die hetsner cloud api die haben die
haben zum glück ein kommando zeilen tool da können wir gleich mal gucken da bin ich
mir noch nicht sicher machen wir es in pisen machen wir es in bash machen wir vielleicht
sogar dotnet programm draus keine ahnung ich fange erst mal mit bash an das scheint mir
am sinnvollsten zu sein mit dem hetsner cloud tool zusammen und dann muss ich den server
anlegen mit n simple aufbau also konfigurieren lassen und dann muss ich den vorgängerserver
wieder löschen weil nur so ist sichergestellt dass ich auch eine neue api bekomme hetsner
ist ja nicht doof für leute die 50 server löschen anlegen löschen anlegen die kriegen
immer die gleiche api dass die inter nicht so viel provisioning aufwand haben aber wenn
ich den alten server erst lösche nachdem ich die neuen angelegt habe und das mache
ich alle paar tage dann ist garantiert das schon obs dann ist garantiert das eine neue
api kriegt und ich habe ja ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vor dass ich wieder api bent werde
weil ich habe meine rates wirklich ordentlich runtergestellt ich meine wenn man sich das
jetzt anguckt das aktualisiert nicht mehr so schnell ja und seitdem bin ich seitdem bin
ich auch bei keinen sachen geplogged übrigens ich habe ich habe heute vorhin ich habe gefixt
ich habe gefixt dass nintendo switch und light vertauscht sind und dass diese dieses komische
play and charge kit für die xbox series x angezeigt wurde wir hatten wir übrigens richtig
professionell oder wir haben sogar einen changelog chat was was sagt ihr dazu die amd grafikkarten
sind grün ja mein factory und alternate alter das soll tausend kosten ok die sind aber
noch nicht so teuer wie wie amd wie nvidia ansible kann auf jeden fall bei headsender
vm professionieren das habe ich noch net ausprobiert kann er das
exquisite api toppen keine so gute idee wenn ich das hier liege im stream
das ist cool dass der das kann
das gefällt mir das kommt man vielleicht direkt mit ansible machen ich fange aber
mal mit nem bash script an ich muss mir erstmal überlegen wie man das ganze macht ja ich
fange erstmal mit dem ich glaube hardcloud heißt das ding mit dem headsender kommando
zeilen tool an oder kann man das hier alles noch ein bisschen noch ein bisschen verbessern
ja also wir machen jetzt erstmal in ein neues neues repo agile def ops scrum
triggert jetzt ist vorbei bann ist raus ja das darf ruhig default master heißen ich
bin da net so ich bin ich an jedem wort ich störe mich nicht an jedem wort was einer
in einem rein technischen zusammenhang ersagt hast du nicht angst dass reseller dein cooles
tool gegen uns normal aus einsetzen könnten wüsste ich jetzt nicht was sie da großartig
machen sollten die könnten mich auch crawlen was ist für musik monka es achte okay das
wird zu geliefer oh exzellent leute wenn auch nicht chrono triggert gespielt hat ich sag
es immer wieder das ist eines der besten spiele aller Zeiten das müsst ihr spielen wenn es
nicht gespielt habe ich weiß es sind 16 bit game und die meisten leute sagen wahrscheinlich
alle 16 bit games und so aber das erkannt man kann es auf dem emulator spielen aber
wer das noch nicht gespielt hat ohne mist das ist echt eines der besten games dies die
je gemacht wurden vom gameplay von der story her von allem ich weiß boomer max aber das
ist wirklich super grafisch ist es auch eines der hübschesten super nintendo games überhaupt
kann ich überhaupt warum kann ich es eigentlich kann ich nicht reloaden für die für die für
die fans gibt sogar gibt sogar in der playstation variante gibt sogar anime short cutscenes
ja
und was mir was mir bei solchen games immer auffällt ist dass ich so 16 bit karakteren
irgendwie so doof klingt ne dass ich so 16 bit karakteren die emotionen mehr abnehmen
als im 3d render es ist merkwürdig ja aber das das liegt wahrscheinlich daran weil man
sich die meiste sache dort dort vorstellen muss ja gibt es gibt es einmal diese szene
hier dass ich meine das ist huge graphics von super nintendo gewesen er ich hab den
ich hab den karakteren übelst die emotionen im game abgenommen was ich bei 3d figuren
nicht so sehr mache ja tales tales auf kannst du dir die ersten tales of games von auch
nice mittlerweile ist das übelst generik haben ich mir nicht mehr gegeben das ist nicht
das war 20 jahre fort nicht reicht nicht ja doch 20 jahre fort to the moon war das es
gibt sogar auf steam mittlerweile ohne mist spiel ich kann es einfach mit emulator spielen
müsste nicht auf steam kaufen aber auf steam ist auf steam ist auf jeden fall die version
mit den mit den anime cutscenes drin aber ich sag wie gesagt wenn ich so nicht gespielt
hab und irgendwie so ein bisschen jrpg sachen was was abgewinnen könnt ohne scheiß das
ist eines der besten spiele die je gemacht worden meiner meinung nach so eines mit dem
nicesten kampfsystem und auch eins mit also ich muss sagen kaum den game ist mir story
telling mäßig so im kopf hängen geblieben wie chrono trigger also wirklich wirklich
top ja genug jetzt werbung gemacht kurz den chat gucken würdest du eher ein kleines
kann man so pauschal nicht sagen to the moon war ähnlich gut ne to the moon war kein game
to the moon war vielleicht story telling mäßig ähnlich gut ja da gäbe ich dir recht aber
to the moon hatte ja keinerlei gameplay chrono trigger ist ein richtiges spiel und auch ein
ziemlich gutes spiel ich kann in ansible secrets nutzen das muss ich mir auch gleich mal angucken
ja deine was ich manche ausdrücke bin ich bin ich zu ich müsste es eigentlich wupp boomer
nennen okay weiter weiter gehts also ich muss jetzt erst mal vor mir das mal eine preis jam
kommt wieder zu also neues repo haben wir am start so und da mach ich mal da kommt der
preis jam rein da kommt irgendwie mein infrascript und mein ansible zeug rein so touch und das
aufbau script nennen wir mal keine an rebuild oder so
vbox ist die echt geldwährung für fortnite skins ah verstehe das habe ich keine ahnung
von ok leute jetzt jetzt wirds jetzt wirds mal kurz kritisch ich muss jetzt api tokens
erstellen und da dürft ihr nicht zugucken
da müsst ihr da müsst ihr leider draußen bleiben ja chat macht die augen zu genau
ok das passt ok alles gut ist weg wunderbar
ok gut ich kann euch da moment
what the fuck mein clipboard manager löscht die history nicht was ist das denn für den
clap alter jetzt habe ich echt ein problem
ok ich reboot mal ich reboot mal reboot reboot hilft bestimmt weil ihr seht gleich wieder
was das ding hat extra einen clear command ok ist es glaub ich nicht mehr drin
ja nice ok alles klar ich kann euch wieder einplanten gut ansonsten ich kann es ja auch
schnell löschen aber alles klar ich blende euch wieder ein
guck steht nix mehr drinne ist aber echt fail ok also jetzt gehen wir mal in unser age
und jetzt probieren wir mal jetzt probieren wir mal einen server anzulegen mit dem hetzener
cloud tool also es gibt das ding hier h cloud und damit kann man server bei hetzener erstellen
und von der idee her also was ich jetzt mal probieren werde und warum ich auch das mit
best script anfangen ist ich glaube das ist relativ schwierig die logik in irgendwelchen
orchestrierungstools abzubilden weil ich will ja zum beispiel quasi den gleichen ich will
den server doppelt erstellen und dann quasi die vorherige sache löschen so dass ich
jeden fall eine neue ip krieg was sind eure top technik trends in den nächsten jahren
web assembly wird auf jeden fall gut abgehen web gpu wird auch abgehen ob blazer abgehen
wird weiß ich nicht javascript wird auf jeden fall weiter abgehen genauso wie die drei großen
javascript frameworks python und ai wird auch übelst weiter abgehen ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass rust beliebter werden wird c++ leider gott ist immer noch auch wenn es die größte
sucker programmiersprache auf der welt ist java wird in china immer beliebter werden
ist es jetzt schon dotnet allerdings auch ganze cloud gedönst und serverless wird noch
mehr werden und es wird vielleicht auch mal sinnvoll gibt es ja jetzt schon sinnvoll
verwendbare serverless functions geben die immer hot sind es wird auf jeden fall immer
mehr bla bla bla as a service geben das ganze cloud zeug wird auch weiterhin in go programmiert
werden auf jeden fall das hat schon seinen grund und wird es ja auch also dass es vieles
jetzt in go ist was haben wir sonst noch so viel technik ist ach keine ahnung fällt mir
jetzt nichts mehr ein reicht erst mal so also wir versuchen jetzt mal einen server zu erstellen
mit dem hetzer cloud tool so und das sollte von der theorie her
ha ha cloud tool help da brauchen wir mal irgendwie so eine übersichtsseite wie das
funktioniert warum ist go so im hype go ist gar nicht
mal so sehr im hype go ist einfach die letzten jahre über hat sich das etabliert für das
ganze cloud zeug so so hundertprozentig sicher warum bin ich mir da auch nicht ja hetzer
docs genau go ganz ehrlich go ist also von zu den aktuell gehalten programmiersprachen
finde ich go persönlich eine der die mir am wenigsten also am unliebsten ist ich hab
ja selbst schon was halbwegs umfangreiches in go gemacht wie gesagt die erste iteration
meiner kameraüberwachungssoftware war ja war ja zumindest die ganze web atte c sache in
go aber go ist so auf der einen seite cool aber es es fehlt so viel du hast irgendwie
fünf verschiedene variablen deklarationen dann gibt es so einfache sachen nicht wie
filter auf den array sondern nur mach eine schleife das sagen die go leute ja ernsthaft
ja also du kannst zum beispiel in normalen programmiersprachen nehmen wir mal sogar
ein javascript ja sogar ein javascript kannst du mittlerweile sowas hier machen gleich dann
kannst du sein array filter oder i größer i größer drei habe ich genannt und da kriegst
du nur die zahlen raus die größer sind als drei das war das ursprungs array dann sagst
array filter und dann kriegst du auch das raus das kann eigentlich so mehr oder weniger
fast jede programmiersprache heute ich mein bei nord scherz habe ich direkt rein klipper
dankeschön aber wie macht ich zeige jetzt nur ein beispielgrad mit natürlich in sie
schaab haben sie es auf die spitze getrieben mit link und link extensions und es klingt
und und x extensions und hast du nicht alles gesehen aber das heißt nicht substorniert
es heißt disabo habe ich letztens auf youtube gelernt disabo und das kann eigentlich fast
jede sprache aber in go geht das nicht und in go also ernsthaft ich mein das ist schon
cool dass man das so filtern kann und auch wirklich praktisch und kurz und knackig und
in go sagen die leute ne ne ne das das braucht man nicht das braucht man nicht go möchte
dass man sagt vor i in array ich weiß gerade aus dem steg greift die die syntax nicht
mehr genau weil ja sagt ich macht gar nicht täglich vor i in array if i größer fünf
dann push neue liste dann so ja genau dann hast du diese komische iterator syntax in
go wo ich mich frage warum muss das echt sein dann weißt du in go manchmal auch nicht ob
was reference ist oder nicht manche manches macht er unter der haube reference manches
nicht dann dann brauchst du manchmal ein sternchen manchmal ein und also es ist schon nicht verkehrt
aber es ist nicht so griffig wie ich mir das wünschen würde go es ist vieles davon übungssache
aber so grundlegende dinge wie dass du schleifen anstatt filtern machen muss ja es ist irgendwie
nicht zeitgemäß ja aber an sich ist gut vor allem das ökosystem eine sache die mir
persönlich auch extrem und wirklich richtig hardcore in go auf den sack geht ist dass
du keine unused imports oben machen kannst also wenn du in go was einbinden willst schreibst
du keine keine import fmt so und bei go ist es so ich kann nicht sagen import fmt import
das import das und es nicht sobald wenn ich es nicht benutze dann kompiliert go nicht
also wenn ich was importiere was ich nicht benutze obwohl ich genau weiß ich brauch das
in zwei minuten kann ich nicht kompilieren oder umgedreht wenn ich im import habe und
ich kommentiere was aus weil ich mal schnell was testen will dann muss ich vorher noch
den import löschen das ist so scheiße das fack mich permanent abbar go keine nicht
benutzen variablen ich kann das verstehen wenn es in dem release bild warnings gibt oder
so ja oder mein wegen sogar aber aber es sollte zumindest ein testmode geben wo das erlaubt
ist oder oder innen oder innen flack womit das erlaubt ist weil es kommt total oft vor
dass man keine ahnung man hat fmt importiert so und man hat irgendwo eine zeile fmt prindeln
ist das ja glaube ich in go machst du bla bla bla so und in go kommentierst du das dann
aus weil du es mal ohne probieren willst und dann kompiliert go nicht weil du den import
hast der nicht mehr benutzt wird weil es kann aus kommentiert aus kommentiert hast ne also
das das kriegt mich richtig auf in go ich mag das eh nicht wenn die die hersteller zu
sehr für einen mitdenken also dass das das das extremste beispiel ist da ruby on rails
da darfst du ja deine variablen auch nicht mal wie du willst groß und klein schreiben
so nach dem motto dann finde das schon nicht mehr aber das geht mir in go auch auf den
keks ich finde und ich weiß ich bin der übelsten dotnet und dotnet core und z sharp fanboy
aber ich finde microsoft hat wirklich ein sehr gutes ich und ihr wisst ich bin ich bin
nur wirklich kein kein microsoft fan und ich hab mich flame die oft genug ja aber microsoft
hatte über die letzten jahre echt ein sehr glückliches händchen was die scharp features
angeht und die haben auch genau das richtige verhältnis von was gebe ich vor und was überlasse
ich den leuten ja die greifen auch manchmal ins klo die projekt konfig ist zum beispiel
auch in dotnet kacke es gibt auch in asb.net course ein paar sachen wo ich mich frage warum
das sein muss aber insgesamt finde ich da wirklich noch am besten ja die fall interface
implementations kann man sich auch echt drüber streiten ob das sinnvoll ist ich muss dir
aber ehrlich sagen ich glaube ich habe es noch nirgendwo verwendet ich weiß aber warum
microsoft die fall interface implementations gemacht hat also bin ich mir relativ sicher
was haben die gemacht rein aus eigeninteresse weil die also ich muss das mal kurz zeigen
was das ist alle dies nicht wissen genau also normalerweise konntest du ein interface anlegen
in dotnet immer so und du konntest eine klasse anlegen die hatte mehrere interfaces dotnet
konnte keine mehrfach vererbung eines der sachen wo ja c++ immer für geflamed wird
du konntest aber mehrere interfaces eine klasse mehrere interfaces implementieren ja das ging
aber auch nur weil interfaces nur gesagt haben wie die metoden heißen müsste du implementieren
nicht wie genau der compiler hat einfach nur geguckt hast du dieses ding definiert wenn
ja ist gut so und das war auch jahrelang so in dotnet das war eigentlich ganz gut muss
man ehrlich gesagt mal sagen für alles andere konnte man abstrakte klassen und sonst was
verwenden und jetzt kam microsoft auf die idee wie wäre es denn wenn man interfaces
die fall implementierung geben könnte also sprich man definiert nicht mehr nur was man
was implementiert werden soll sondern wenn deine klasse das nicht implementiert dann
gibt es in die fall implementierung was bedeutet c sharp hat auf einschlag mehrfach vererbung
bekommen bekommen und merkwürdige dinger wo ich mich frage ob das wirklich so eine
gute idee war aber ich weiß warum die es gemacht haben also ich glaube zumindest zu
wissen warum die das gemacht haben microsoft selbst hat absolut interface hell guckt euch
mal direkt x an texture 1 2 3 4 5 x was ist swapchen 1 x swapchen x x x swapchen 2 3
4 5 x die haben interface hell des todes ich glaube die haben das rein aus aus eigennutz
gemacht bei microsoft so ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben wir wollen selber bei hetzer anlegen
zu viel geschwätzt wenn ich sehe schon wir kommen wieder nix zu nix und extension method
finde ich viel schöner viel viel nicer übrigens eine sache die c++ x also wirklich das eines
auch wieder nur meine meinung nach ja aber eines der features was c++ wirklich zu einer
halbwegs brauchbaren sprache machen könnte wären extension methods weil dann kannst
du die die rost default implementierung die c++ in manchen fällen hat wenigstens extenden
mit eigenen lips auf github oder sonst was ohne dass du inkompatibel zu anderen sachen
wirst weil du unterschiedliche typen verwendest also extension methods wäre glaube ich was
was c++ noch halbwegs brauchbar machen könnte du könntest dann zum beispiel die die standard
c++ standard string klasse verwenden die einfach nur abgrundtief sagt wenn du irgendwas wirklich
mit einem text machen willst und du kannst sie weiter verwenden aber mit extension methods
kannst du die zu einer halbwegs brauchbaren klasse du kannst deine ordentlichen unicode
support reinbauen kannst du ordentlich groß klein schreiben und konvertieren reinbauen
ordentliches zählen alles mögliche reinbauen über extension methods und du wirst trotzdem
kompatibel bleiben zu allem was standard string verwendet das wäre nice aber das c++ creme
hat sich gedacht ne ne wir bauen lieber noch bessere template funktionen ein die fünf
leute auf der welt verstehen der unterschied zwischen extension method und einfachen vererben
ist dass die klasse sich gar nicht ändert also es ist ja exakt der gleiche typ wie vorher
und du kannst die buch of panache kein mist erzählen du kannst die c++ standard string
klasse auch nicht gescheit extend ich bin mir nicht sicher ob du ob c++ das kann aber
ich glaube c++ ist so schlau und checkt es wenn du eine abgeleitete klasse übergibst
dass der die base klasse nimmt aber du hast keinen zugriff auf viele internen sachen von
standard string also wobei dann bringen die extension methods auch nichts jetzt eine gute
frage ist eine gute frage ja es hat es hat seinen grund ich bin mir aber grad selbst
nicht so ganz sicher warum man nicht einfach ne ok keine ahnung kann ich dir grad nicht
gescheit beantworten so also wir wollten aber ein server bei hetzer anlegen wir kommen
überhaupt nicht zur sache also h cloud create so viel weiß ich create server also von der
idee her wollen wir jetzt folgendes machen ich will den script was den server anlegt
also ja genau also was den server anlegt den ordentlich konfiguriert und danach den
gleichen server wieder also ich will ich will server rotate ich habe keine ahnung ob man
das versteht was ich meine also mann genommen ich habe mann genommen ich hätte den server
mit dem namen eins so dann will ich den zweiten server ein anlegen mit dem namen keine ahnung
eins und underscore eins oder so und dann will ich wenn der fertig aufgebaut ist will ich
den alten server löschen und dann den neuen verwenden und beim nächsten run will ich das
gleiche mit dem jetzt erstellten server machen also sprich ich will so will die durch rotaten
was den vorteil hat ich krieg garantiert immer eine neue ip und es ist so wenig downtime wie
möglich weil ich kann die server parallel aufbauen und warten bis der zweite läuft und
dann lösche ich den ersten das sind nur fünf minuten die machen die mehrkosten nicht aus
aber es hat kaum downtime und ich krieg garantiert neue ip deine rechnung ist dann 200 seiten
langs interessiert mich nicht die rechnung wird aber nicht höher ob die rechnung 200
seiten lang ist juckt mich nicht äh soldat ich bastel das jetzt mal dann sieht mann was
ich machen will ok also wir wollen server anlegen wie geht
das jetzt h cloud create server help ah ist schon die hilfe help ok was brauchen wir jetzt
image image server was ist jetzt richtig
ist das auch alles doch heißt aktuell schon ich bin mir aber nicht sicher ob ich das
wieder mache image ich brauche mal ein beispiel wie wie gehen da kram server erstellen h cloud
docks hetzner h cloud haben doch bestimmt bestimmt nur hetzner cloud api genau sehr
gut server servers die haben ganz gute docks ist mir schon öfters mal aufgefallen create
a server ok ok das ist jetzt über jason wie geht das mit dem wie geht das mit dem tool
also was übergeben die da jetzt name name location data center ok probieren wirs mal
aus also wahrscheinlich muss ich sowas hier machen image gleich ubuntu 20.4 ah ne image
image image so äh kann doch nicht so kompliziert sein wie man den kram verwendet alter ich
habe auch ein beispiel mal wenn ich ein beispiel habe weiß ich wie der kram aufgebaut ist
ja h cloud server create da muss ich immer noch name und so ach hier kommt mal moment
server create nicht create server ah server create ah jetzt kommen wir der sache schon
näher exquisite alles klar und dann name ok so jetzt müssen wir uns einen guten namen
dafür ausdenken dass ich die server wieder erkenne wir machen erstmal image image da
weiß ich ja schon was ich brauche ubuntu 20.4 ich hoffe das heißt bei denen so type type
ist glaube ich hetsner cloud pricing hetsner sollte mich sponsoren so viel werbung ich hier
im stream mache für die leute klippt das mal ich schicke das morgen hetsner ich sag
ich und was haltet ihr von der idee ohne wiss ich mach so viel werbung indirekt für die
hier im stream da könnte man auch da könnte man wenigstens auch mal richtig echte werbung
drinnen machen machen wir bei hetsner bannereien dann hat hetsner ordentlich was von ich meine
die gucken gerade wieder 300 leute zu die alle technik interessiert sind die auch in
dem bereich arbeiten und ich glaube da haben alle was davon da mache ich bannereien ab
und zu mal so hetsner auferlehren da kriege ich ein bisschen was hetsner hat ordentlich
was von das das sollten wir mal machen ja da brauchen wir rabattcode poc fps genau scotch
dankeschön für den sub scotchow drei monat dankeschön nice ok weiter weiter beim bauer
läuft hetsner wäre ernsthaft cool dann ich schreibe die echt mal morgen an habe ich
eine gute idee also genau also sprich bei bei typen muss man jetzt angeben was man für
einen server typ haben will ich will den da haben cpx 2 1 ich glaube cpx sind die sind
die cpx nicht die die auf epic laufen die cx in zeleron und die cpx in sind epics na
also cpx 2 1 weiß ich ob man das klein schreit kann man wahrscheinlich schreit man mal groß
so cpx 2 1 zum server erstellen durch dich bin ich echt zu hetsner gekommen also erfolgt
deine erfarte deine werbung schon mal ja genau das das müssen wir müssen wir den mal sagen
ja ich sehe dass nachher den clips passt da ist dass ich geklippt habe so also was müssen
wir noch angeben nehmen so jetzt jetzt muss ich mir mal ein bisschen überlegen wie ich
den kram nenne und zwar ich will den server ja wieder finden wie gesagt ich will immer
zwei server abwechseln habe ich warum habe ich in meiner scheld kein kein aus kommentieren
zu fack muss ich gleich erst mal das ausschalten kann also ich brauche einen namen den ich
wieder finde wie gesagt das ganze setzt sich zusammen aus einem frontend und drei werker
server die nenne ich einfach auch werker werker werker 1 soll jetzt brauche ich noch nie unik
in unik name dafür dass ich den wieder wieder erkenne also wie gesagt ich will das ganze
durch rotieren ich will den server erstellen und quasi den gleichen server den ich letztes
mal erstellt habe dann löschen nachdem der aktuelle aufbau wieder drinne ist pack doch
hetsner rafflings auf den preis jam deine rechnung wird dann dadurch ewig lang ja aber
ist doch nicht schlimm oder ich meine den juckt dann habe ich halt dann habe ich halt
habe ich halt 30 zeilen in der rechnung ist doch nicht schlimm also mich juckt das nicht
wieso 720p 48 fps weil das flüssiger ist als 30 und nicht so viel bandbreite brauche
wie 60 datum anhängen an den namen ja ich habe ich habe ich mir auch gerade überlegt
wir machen so denn wir machen einfach nen date oder so date wie sagt man date noch mal
prozent plus s war das prozent s ok genau und jetzt brauche ich das passende wobei
so ein timestamp ist ok wir nehmen einfach den timestamp der timestamp ist einfach immer
unique das passt doch das müsste das müsste eigentlich müsste eigentlich nehmen was mache
ich denn das müsste doch eigentlich gut passen das müsste eigentlich auch gut passen so
jetzt erstellt er nen server ubuntu 20 20 04 ist es auch der 3 core mit dem namen wirka
ok geht das jetzt invalid input name warum ist das warum ist das invalid ok wir probieren
zwar nur mit wirka geht das denn muss ich das klein schreiben cpx ah guck mal jetzt da
wieder erstellt es created leute das ist schlecht wenn er das root password anzeigt das ist nicht
gut wenn er das root password auf der shell anzeigt das ist nichts ist keine so gute idee
ne leute so schnell habt ihr das root password nicht abgetippt das glaube ich nicht das ist
definitiv keine gute idee gewesen ok kann ich dem ding irgendwie beibringen dass er das fucking
root password nicht anzeigt im stream ja mit ssh key hoffentlich zeigt er das root password
nicht an ja ich kann es da auch noch was siehe clip was für einen clip hast du das follow
mls das glaube ich dir nicht dass du das so schnell abgetippt hast das glaube ich dir
nicht klipp und in der wenn man in ssh key generiert wird kein root hinterlegt ok ich
hoffe der server ist jetzt auch weg ok zum glück sonst machen die leute irgendwelchen
hacker irgendwelche hacker mans hier drauf ok ssh key also wie hinterlegen wir denn ssh
key zeig mal her so also wie hinterlegt man ssh key wahrscheinlich
minus minus ssh key der server ist leute der server ist schon längst weg ich hab den
grad wieder gelöscht der ist der ist nicht mehr existent der ist weg da könnt ihr euch
auch nicht mehr drauf einloggen cloud wie listed man eigentlich seine server list server
list ergibt nichts sehr gut oder ls ja aber es ist wahrscheinlich list ich hab da ich
hab also ich hab ja list du bist trotzdem drin immer noch eingeloggt auf dem down auf
dem server der nicht mehr oben ist exzellent ok weiter jetzt hoffen wir dass er kein root
password anzeigt sonst muss ich den gleich wieder löschen ssh key ich hab nen ssh key
hinterlegt der nennt sich test at test auch toller name serverless ist das genau so ok
chat wollen wir es riskieren wollt ihr zugucken ich kann das ding ja schnell wieder löschen
nee nee nee ich lass euch nicht zugucken nice ok chat es hat funktioniert da server erstellt
worker1 und es wird kein root password angezeigt so mal gucken ob man sich drauf verbinden
kann ich werde schon mal in weißer voraussicht strict host key checking auf no stellen weil
ich mir wahrscheinlich mich jetzt 50 mal auf der gleichen ip einloggen werde so da ist
er so jetzt mal kurz kontrollieren war das hier die gleiche ip wie das letzte mal eins
drei fünf also zwei zwei vier sechs hinten und davor war es wo ist das mit dem root password
zwei eins neun null zwei vier sechs gucken wir mal ob die den surfer ordentlich resettet
haben oder ob das gleiche root password immer noch funktioniert wie kann man denn wie kann
man denn password ausforsen oder ist password aus vielleicht sogar aus wenn man ssh force
password aus prefer aha ahja ok nice haben sie gut gemacht haben sie gut gemacht alles
alles gut keine heckermans hier drinnen keine heckermans am start alles klar außer der
chat der ist natürlich wieder drinnen ok sehr schön ok also so legt man schon mal
so aber an gut zu wissen ha cloud server wie kannst du das root password jetzt selber
ändern ich glaube es ist gar kein root password gesetzt ehrlich gesagt vermute ich jetzt
mal aber ich könnte einfach pass passwd machen oder kann ich neues password vergeben wenn
ich will ja ja genau hast du passwort geliegt nee nee nee hab ich nicht hetzner hat passwort
geliegt aber der server ist schon längst wieder weg ok also ha cloud server list und
wie löscht man den kram jetzt wieder ha cloud server help remove rebuild ach guck mal man
kann sogar reset passwort machen über den das machen wir jetzt aber net delete delete
server exquisite also server lists und dann braucht man wahrscheinlich die id denke ich
mal server delete mal gucken ob auch sowas hier geht könnte ja sein nee anon flag dann
wahrscheinlich die id ich hab den in helsinki gebaut ja das ist sogar gut wenn ich den helsinki
baue dann baue ich dir nämlich an allen drei standorten ein jetzt müssen wir nur noch
gucken genau also dann erstelle ich nämlich ein server von von den von den workern in
helsinki ein in nuremberg und einem in falten falten dings passt doch drei server drei standorte
exquisite alles klar jetzt muss ich nur mal kurz gucken wie man jetzt die location location
datacenter ja ok was sind was sind denn die korrekten hetzner locations hetzner ha cloud
location die haben die haben helsinki das heißt glaube ich hell hell nbg fsm
das ist eine gute idee ha ha cloud location list nice excellent location
dann also man kann all die all die nehmen oder oder oder name ok mal mal all die man sollte
jetzt was in in in fsn 1 erstellen postchamp nice sehr schön da ist er kann man wieder löschen
jetzt kommen ordentlichen server name vergeben also wir hatten ja gesagt underscore date plus
genau für den für den timestamp plus prozent s invalid input but why vielleicht mit dem
underscore echt nice koch im underscore ok selber erstellt genau wirka 1 minus timestamp
sehr schön excellent warum funktioniert denn keine underscores gibt es da eigentlich autocomplete
für das wäre ex das wäre mal extrem ha cloud autocomplete oder gibt autocomplete für messif
server delete ane aber das funktioniert guck mal der hat autocomplete für die server das
ja cool da muss ich gar nicht nachgucken sehr gut huge ok also das da brauchen wir schon mal
das richtspoggers ah der setzt als aus dem ja ok das ergibt sinn das ergibt sinn dass
das da nicht funktioniert ja das ist recht moment wo habe ich das suche ich nicht wo
habe ich mein big brain wo ist mein big brain emote leute ich finde es nicht mehr hier ist
es alles klar da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen ok also infraroops what the fuck so rebuild
es ist aber wie sieht es mit autocomplete aus shell so bin bash ok wir wollen drei server anlegen
also vor ihm vielleicht vielleicht machen was erstmal alle bvw weise nur in der schleife aber
wir machen erst mal nur einen ha cloud so also wir wollen den server anlegen und zwar ob und
tu bla wirka der soll nicht eins heißen sondern da soll dementsprechend wirka wirka 123 heißen
in dem fall und location passt ja wie die faust aufs auge location machen wir auch zwischen
123 durch passt eigentlich relativ gut 95 so ok und jetzt und jetzt ich lasse es einmal laufen
damit ich weitermachen kann aber das ist nicht in uns weg der übung so soll es eigentlich nicht
sein rebuild erst mal gucken ob es funktioniert botnetzwerk ink das gute ist der apk selbst wenn
ich den apk irgendwie geleakt hätten sollte kann man das nur in diesem projekt verwenden ok so und
von der idee was ich jetzt machen will ist ich will ich will den server anlegen dann will ich
ansible laufen lassen und dann will ich den alten server vom gleichen typ also den alten
wirka eins löschen das machen wir doch jetzt dass das können wir doch mal ausprobiert es
funktioniert also ich muss jetzt erst mal rausfinden wie der alte wie der alte server heißt das
heißt ich muss jetzt irgendwas mit server server list machen oder so ja genau es muss funktionieren
ich mein in dem fall mit den ganzen jason responses und sowas wäre das wahrscheinlich
in einem in einer ordentlichen programmier sprache mit einem ordentlichen restline einfacher aber
wir machen das weiter mit dem bestuhl kram läuft da überall so also list wir brauchen jetzt die
id von dem server der schon wirka 1 heißt schblick so big brain tool ja ne ne ne mit mit mit mit
ansible ist das glaube ich nicht so einfach was ich vor hab oder kannst du das mit ansible auch
so das habe ich schon gesehen kannst du das mit ansible auch so rotate ich will ja erst eine
neuen server aufbauen der wirka 1 heißt und danach wenn der da ist will ich will ich den kram wieder
löschen so krepp wirka 1 und jetzt brauche ich die id von dem ding ja gut das ist einfach karte
links f1 ist die id easy habe ich die id von dem server von dem alten ok das war jetzt mal also
wir machen mal sogar die back aus bar auf ausgabe rating server dass man bescheid weiß
dann merke ich mir den alten alten server wie old id dann lege ich den neuen an dann lasse
ich ansible laufen und dann lösche ich den alten server also hr cloud server delete old id so weit
von der theory her hast du dir am sonntag oder so schon mal die fanshowdown videos von major
hardware ich weiß nicht wer major hardware ist ne so also der sollte jetzt eine neues image
erstellen wenn es erstellt ist sollte er das alte löschen so weit von der theorie ob das
jetzt klappt ich gucke mal ob ich mir noch die ip irgendwie raus raus gekreppt kriege dann kann
ich die nämlich die infos noch anzeigen welches feld brauche ich denn da jetzt 5 6 7 wir sind
das bei running ok das mache ich anders das sagt grepp oh running grepp kann keine matching groups
ne grepp oh running wie kriege ich das jetzt am besten raus ich meine ich meine ich könnte
das jetzt aber schön ist was anderes wie kriege ich wie kriege ich ermöglicht elegant jetzt die
ip raus aus der ausgabe von dem server du könntest per regex die ip regex sind doof
column ging doch irgendwie oder mit awk column column basch column fourth oder so ja das moment
geht das ohne irgendwas kann ich ohne ohne delimiter geht das
funktioniert nicht die sind ich glaube die cloudfile sind sogar minuten genau abgerechnet
ja ok mit awk könnten was machen ja das stimmt das ist dem egal ob es tab ist aber ich dachte
man konnte direkt sagen column column 2 oder so ne das macht keinen unterschied das macht
keinen unterschied ob da aber wir sind wir sind heute ein bisschen stack overflow driven beste
und das sagt noch einer zu programmieren muss man irgendwie was können das einfach copy paste
ok ja dann machen wir es doch mit awk dann ist das wahrscheinlich die einfachste variante ok
awk 1 ist dann die aldi und awk 1 2 3 4 what the fuck ich muss auch kratten habe ich vergessen ok
ich muss auch kratten grepp nach werker 1 excellent ok dann dann merken wir uns das jetzt mal also
alt alt ip ist dann werker 1 genau man muss wissen wie man googelt so so sehe ich das auch
dann das ist oftmals gar nicht so einfach dass man weiß dann was man suchen muss so also jetzt
habe ich die alte aldi die alte ip und jetzt kann ich das rotate rotate und aufbauen wofür
ich das kripp brauche ich will meine preis jam infrastruktur neu erstellen können und ich will
die server rotate und aufbauen also sprich ich will erstens sich erstellen dass ich eine neue
ip kriege das geht dadurch dass ich den neuen server erst erstelle und dann den alten lösche
ja und halt so dass es möglichst wenig geld kostet dass die möglichst kurz parallel laufen
aber auch so dass es wenig downtime gibt und ip na das das kann ich kann ich dann zum debug
verwenden die lead old server und da machen wir jetzt hier echo ip is
weil brauchen wir das gar nicht an der stelle ip is old ip und aldi ich gebe das einfach mal
aus das sieht dann wahrscheinlich besser aus und vielleicht auch ganz praktisch so und das
sollte jetzt doch eigentlich schon funktionieren bevor wir die ganze endselbild geschichte machen
also sprich da sucht sich den alten server raus merkt sich das und create ein neues image und wenn
das image create ist dann löscht er den alten server okay also von der idee her wenn ich das
jetzt laufen lasse oh ich muss hier aus dem create ich muss aus dem create mir auch noch die
sachen rauskippen ja serverlist kann ja die an der ap excess macht es nicht fett ich muss
noch mal den create von hand ausführen und mir noch mal des des output den output merken dass
ich am output gleich mal eine runde rumklappen kann ja hier mal doppel da löschen wir den alten
wieder zack output also sprich wie kriege ich das am besten hier die ip raus das ist einfach das
ist immer das erste fällt also kreppen wir einmal nach einmal nach server da kriegen wir nur das und
dann ist es wirklich kat minus f 2 muss man ja jetzt haben die limiter angeben genau und dann
ist die ip ist einfach das gleiche nur mit ip v4 excellent doch mal frage was bringt hier ein
rotating also das bringt dass ich garantiert eine neue ip kriege auf dem jeweiligen server dass
es nicht unnötig viel kostet weil ich die nicht lange überlappend da habe und dass der zweite
server auf jeden fall da ist bevor ich den ersten lösche und so und die downtime quasi so gut wie
nicht vorhanden ist so also sagen wir jetzt mal hier output oder out einfach nur out abkürzen
beste jetzt diesen ganzen crap hier rein echo out und dann kommt hier die ip und dann kommt
das raus also das müsste so funktionieren das muss ich noch quoten sonst checkt das
wegen den zeilen nicht so und dann ist das hier ip ne das id so und jetzt bin ich echt mal
gespannt ob der kram funktioniert warum kein web proxy weil es gar nicht so einfach ist
finde mal ordentliche proxys die dann auch nicht geblockt sind das ist ip ich habe es bei proxy
gemacht aber das hat nicht gescheit funktioniert server wechseln brauche ich nur für den fall dass
ich geblockt werde ich habe jetzt ja mein ganzes zeug so weit runter geschraubt dass
ich eigentlich nicht mehr geblockt werden das läuft jetzt auch schon zwei tage ohne dass
irgendwas ist ich meine ich mache im prinzip weniger traffic als die oma die ab und zu mal
die seite refreshed serious marks top kann kann es nicht nein kein qw ok und jetzt geben
wir jetzt geben wir die ip aus und es funktioniert echo kopieren uns das einfach so ok und da
hier zwischendurch kommt als n simple zeug so von der idee hier sollte der jetzt alten server
gucken wir gucken immer zu alten server neuen server erstellen und dann alten server löschen
danach also wir sollten danach ein wirken eins haben mit neuen time stamp und dieser und dieser
6056 hinten sollte weg sein die sind verfügbar aber amazon hat wahrscheinlich einfach nicht
aktualisiert so rating server
hey das hat funktioniert neuer server ist da alter server ist weg gleicher typ gleich alles
so wie sein soll also der rotate jetzt so 6 285 für das ganze noch mal aus wir gucken
ihm jetzt mal live zu bei guck zweiter zweiter surfer wird erstellt danach und danach sollte
direkt der erste gelöscht werden wenn es durch rotated ist ja nice genau so soll es sein
sehr schön nice das gefällt mir wir haben wir haben sogar noch halbwegs brauchbare ausgabe
das def nullen wir war weil das war kommt erst mal draußen ok und jetzt kommt das jetzt
jetzt wirds big brain ensemble time ok also das rotating funktioniert schon mal dann sollten
wir jetzt noch gucken die location sollten wir vielleicht noch angeben irgendwie in location
ja gut woher weiß ich denn was was ist woher weiß ich denn was was ist lohnt sich das zu
metten location list ja ich habe auch schon gesagt ich schreibe mal jetzt am morgen an ich
mache so viel werbung für die ja eins ist fissen und drei ist hell in die hölle in hell sind
die hier wobei ehrlich gesagt ist mir das doch vollkommen egal das muss ich nicht mit mir
schreibt er einfach 1 2 3 hin und gut ist guckt hier ich würde es noch mal aus wie bild location
1 reicht doch da muss doch da muss doch nicht hell sind die drin stehen oder nur im berg oder
so reicht doch dass ich weiß dass das location 1 ist und dass es überall anders ist reicht da
muss gar nicht können wir noch verfeinern ok jetzt kommt machen random nee auf kein darf kann ich
nicht machen dann kriege ich doppelte ip ist mit pech also die gleichen noch mal wenn er
nämlich zweimal hintereinander dann zufälliger weis auf gleiche rz kommt und inzwischen hat
kein anderer den server aufgebaut hat dann habe ich die gleiche ip von vorher und das will ich
ja gar nicht ok jetzt jetzt kommt jetzt kommt das ansible zeug da wird es jetzt ein bisschen
big big brainiger wir haben doch noch unser ansible zeug vom letzten mal jetzt ist nur die
frage cd temp ansible ne wo ach du scheiße cd repos ansible ach du große scheiße wo habe
ich das letzte mal habe ich das in meinem git ok wenn ich es aber zu meinem git geändert
habe dann muss ich es auch irgendwo lokal finden cd ansible ach so das heißt ja perfekt
ich habe das geerdet ich habe sogar noch was dran gemacht danach massive death ops big brain
ok wo war unser playbook vom letzten mal da das brauchen wir jetzt ich war mal kurz
wischl studio auf so das ganze zeug was wir hier ohne haben brauchen wir nicht kadi zeug
kommt weg preis champ kommt weg wir brauchen eigentlich erst mal nur die sachen bis firewall
einschalten weil das gibt jetzt ja nicht den preis das preis champ den preis champ front
end server das gibt jetzt ja die die back end geschehen also die die die worker crawler
geschichte dementsprechend müssen wir auch nicht htp htp erlauben die musik hin genau
also und host muss auch weg und leute wie kann man ansible direkt auf eine ip ausführen
ohne inventory weiß das jemand google google ansible direct ip how to run ansible without
specifying inventory genau das brauchen wir was einfach die ip hinten dran schreiben
das kann ich an den kommer hinten dran ernsthaft das funktioniert jetzt seriously ok das ist
ein bug oder dass das funktioniert mit einem kommer hinten dran weil gewollt wäre das
die abenteuerlichste sündtags aller zeiten kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass das gewollt
ist aber das probieren wir jetzt mal aus ob das funktioniert also mal mal hosts raus
nehmen was sollte man reinschreiben hosts aus all it's not a bug ja da bin ich mir
gerade nicht so sicher so und jetzt kopieren wir uns das ansible playbook mal nämlich
base nach a child defops kram und die ansible konf kopieren wir uns auch die brauchen wir
bestimmt noch was steht denn da drin inventory kann raus house checking genau du kannst
ein in memory inventory erstellen und zu runtime die ip als variable übergeben ok aber wenn
ich einfach so machen kann wäre ja noch einfacher das probieren wir mal aus ob das funktioniert
ha cloud server list wir fühlen ich fühle es jetzt einfach mal auf so einer kiste aus
so also aber das mit dem kommer das ist schon eine der merkwürdigsten sündtags für direkt
die ich die ich bisher gesehen habe ok habe ich kein base jammeln so von der idee sollte
ansible jetzt da hingehen auf den server und ab update machen basic tools installieren
die firewall aktivieren ssh erlauben und firewall aktivieren das jetzt funktioniert
schein zu gehen stack overflow leute ich sag es immer wieder man muss einfach nur wissen
nach was man sucht ja ja man muss einfach nur wissen nach was man sucht aktuell ist
noch nix installiert aber sobald das hier durch ist sollte der frisch geupgraded sein
und tools installiert was natürlich echt nice ist weil dann kann ich die neuen server
createn über die cloud api ich kann ansible installieren ansible das ding konfigurieren
lassen bis zu bis zu worker anwendung starten und wenn das alles fertig ist und das connect
das zum frontend dann lösche ich den alten server das größte rätsel ist immer woher
wissen sie das auf stack overflow ja die wissen es wahrscheinlich von stack exchange
aber warum ist es ein comma hinten dran das verstehe ich nicht das ergibt überhaupt
keinen sinn aber ansible logik ist mir egal hauptsache es funktioniert genau und die
von stack exchange wissen von stack overflow und irgendwann explodiert es wegen endlos
schleife wo ich wobei wobei ich mache ja eh nur noch if schleifen so kann er das jetzt
mal update cloud flair api ich muss die cloud flair api nicht umbiegen weil das frontend
ja immer das gleiche bleibt das sind die dinger die die backend die sachen einliefern
so er ist durchgelaufen jetzt sollte ich den t-marks haben das ist ja cool das funktioniert
richtig gut und es ist auch nur noch ein server da oder jawohl nur ein server da genauso
wie es sein soll guck mal das ist ja richtig nice also sprich der legt neuen server an
konfiguriert den über ansible das muss übrigens noch einstellen ja dollar api ich mach da
mal klammern drum weil der bash weiß nie genau bis wohin sowas geht der legt neuen
server an konfiguriert ihn und löst dann den alten das ist genauso rolling wie ich
das brauche exzellent exzellent das gefällt mir richtig gut so und jetzt ist natürlich
die große preisfrage wie kriegen wir mit ansible das ding so konfiguriert dass das
street merchant drauf läuft kann ansible git repos klonen weil ich glaube die einfachste
variante ist da gar nichts zu großartig vercontainerisieren ich mein street merchant sieht erstmal so
aus als läuft als docker also das ding das ist ja das was ich im hintergrund benutze
um webseiten zu durchsuchen das läuft zwar recht easy im docker aber ich glaube die
einfachste variante ist tatsächlich das komplett ohne docker zu machen ich installiere
einen node drauf klone das repo und es ist gut ok wie klont man mit ansible ein repo
joho das könnte ich auch machen ne könnte ich nicht machen das ding hat massig cpu last
das muss ich verteilen ich werde das so machen die erste kiste kriegt keine ahnung 7 7 sachen
die zweite kiste kriegt 7 sachen und die dritte kiste kriegt 7 sachen dann lohnt sich das
nämlich mit den 3 cpu kern auch nur mit proxy ist zu zu zu viel für eine kiste dann müsste
ich weiter meine 16 core behalten plus plus noch 3 1 core dinger das ist irgendwie auch
nicht so schön ich glaube es ist besser wenn man die jeweils da auf den backhandler auf
einem dass er aber laufen lässt ok wie klont man den repo mit ansible so zeige ich mal her
wie geht denn das geht repo des version ne version brauchen wir nicht einfach einfach
das aktuellste ich mache das mal ich mache das mal im studio auf get klone get klone
street merchant nach root natürlich mir lasse alles unter root laufen root street merchant
so und da klonen wir nicht das offizielle repo sondern mines mein fork weil da sind
ein paar fixes drin dass es besser funktioniert für mich das da ja da habe ich da habe ich
gefixt dass das die die switch auf amazon crawled die neuesten minefactory alternate
urls und dass das mqtt zeug funktioniert so ne das kann man forken das ist erlaubt auf
github sonst würde github gar nicht funktionieren so ok und jetzt klont er den kram in das repo
ok also das probieren jetzt mal aus da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt also von der idee her
also von der idee er sollte jetzt einen neuen server erstellen komplett das drauf machen
repo klonen und danach den alten server löschen ok
der neue server ist auf jeden fall schon mal am erstellen follow milz stufe 1 dankeschön
für den sub oh das ging ein bisschen schnell monka whoop whoop es was habe ich verkehrt
gemacht
aber die eindrückung ist falsch jammel keck weh alter sollte ich vielleicht mal ein bash
script um den set e machen dass der immer ab bricht wenn er wenn ein fehler ach komm
unsere sachen sind so gut self documenting programmiert da gibt es keine fehler ok also
jetzt legt ein zweiter surfer an jetzt sollte den eigentlich erstmal provision provisionen
anachter sehr gut bevor er genau warum löst alter wo ist das problem no root fuck ich bin
zu schnell ich bin zu schnell ich muss warten der surfer ist noch nicht bereit während ich
wenn ich versuche ein simple drauf auszuführen entweder leute wir haben jetzt zwei wir haben
jetzt zwei möglichkeiten was soll man machen soll wir einfach mal ein sleep von zehn sekunden
rein machen oder sollen wir die big brain variante machen mit irgendwie einem ping oder
einem ssh login und eine wild schleife drum herum easy variante oder big brain big brain
variante bin ich auch für massive brain agile ja die agile variante machen wir so so chat
ihr habt ihr habt die richtige hands on mentalität so macht man das wild true du erst erstmal
schön endlos schleife fabrizieren so dann machen wir noch ein echo mit einem punkt
dass ich sehe ob er eine endlos schleife hängt oder nicht genau das dachte ich mir auch ich
führe jetzt einfach ssh so lange aus bis es funktioniert also ssh minus o strikt ach du
scheiße wie ging das minus so hier alles klar strikt horst key checking no weil das ist
gar nicht mehrfach belegt jetzt schon während ich das probiere root at ip exit einfach wobei
was ich glaube ich glaube er muss gar nichts angeben oder auf jeden fall exit exit schadet
auf jeden fall auch nicht so viel fehlermeldung braucht kein mensch der f0 so und wenn das
funktioniert dann machen wir break ok das ist zwar nicht schön aber das müsste von
der idee funktionieren hast du eine idee für drei verschiedene server konfix ja entweder
mache ich ein template oder ich mache einfach wirka 1 konf wirka 2 konf wirka 3 konf und
schiebt dann je nachdem was hier in der schleife drin steht drüber ja das habe ich gesagt
dass er das ignoriert ok noch mal probieren wartet jetzt bis der server ready ist oh oh
ich sollte da vielleicht noch ein sleep ich ich sollte da vielleicht noch ein sleep rein
machen sleep 1 aber das funktioniert schon mal nice wait until finished das funktioniert
glaub nicht das ist nur bis der server bei den erstellt es nicht bis er direkt verfügbar
ist aber von der idee klappt da schon mal
ich meine ich könnte hier drin auch gleich das ensemble playbook ausführen wobei ich
mache es mal so beim ssh weiß ich auf jeden fall dass es dann tut was liebt 0,5 meint
es ist besser 1 reicht wieso funktioniert die synchronisierung wird zwischen windows
mail und gmail manchmal weil windows mail sagt im zweifelsfall liegt das an windows
mail sonnabird besser auf jeden fall sonnabird imap alles gut
die best syntax ja das ist keck leo kleingeschrieben ein anderes
emote als keck leo großgeschrieben dann brauche ich das auch weil das ist eines meiner neuesten
lieblings lachlul emotes auf twitch haben leider nicht so viele outlook naja will ich
eigentlich keinem empfehlen outlook nimm mal lieber sonnabird mit imap outlook ist eher
sowas wenn man irgendwelches business gedöns noch sünken will und guck mal da leute das
funkt das funkt was habe ich falsch gemacht was
da ist kein sonntagsfehler schell
ld id was muss das liebt nicht vorn break nö wenn der break ist vorbei wenn der wenn
der nicht break dann es liebte einmal moin chain lore ok ich hab keine ahnung warum das
jetzt da ld was der hier rumspackt vielleicht muss man das irgendwie bash mäßig so machen
oder so immer quoten aber es hat es hat wahrscheinlich funktioniert ruma es hat es hat funktioniert
leading all server jawohl hat funktioniert da hat den neuen server aufgebaut kann man
es gleich ausprobieren ob alles funktioniert hat er meint no strick tosky checking kann
man ausprobieren ob alles funktioniert hat zack auf den neuen server drauf t-max ist
drauf jawohl und hier ist das street merchant drauf sehr schön nice und es ist auch mein
street merchant weil man sieht der wubblers hat committed oh chat ihr seid wieder richtig
big brain heute hätte ich gar nicht gesehen mail liegt ne die mail ist nicht liegt die
ist schon bekannt das ist die mail wo man auch donated mit paypal drauf die habe ich
extra für den stream gemacht also aber man kann nicht mehr donate mit paypal und die
steht eh public im git also das ist nix nix geleaktes so ok das funktioniert ja ich bin
begeistert so wir müssen jetzt noch als einen schnur noch unser ensemble script insofern
anpassen dass der auf fack leute wir brauchen eine note js drauf dass ich das laufen lassen
kann das habe ich jetzt ganz vergessen wir brauchen ein 14er node js dann vielleicht
doch lieber im container wobei nur in note 14 kann er nicht so kompliziert zu installieren
sein ja man kann donaten aber ich habe den link nicht mehr drin es gibt keinerlei notifications
oder sonst irgendwas und ich habe das auch nicht mal verlinkt mit donation hier irgendwie
im profil weiter der donation link nicht klappt und die notifications nicht klappen also sprich
ich bekomme es schlicht ergreifend nicht mit wenn einer donatet ok jetzt habe ich echt
jetzt ok jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken wie man Ubuntu note 14 wie installiert man note
14 install 14 also in den repos ist es glaube ich nicht drin abt info node js ne da ist
10 19 drin und das ist zu alt für den crawler haben die offizielle debian rear fokus moment
was habe ich für den ubuntu ne was ist denn issue.net was ist ubuntu 20.04.5 codename
ah das ist das ok passt dann können wir das eigentlich direkt direkt nehmen lsb release
minus ah nice der chat kennt sich aus ah das ist gut zu wissen also sprich eigentlich
können wir dann das direkt eintragen lassen ok also ansible add apt repo machen wir das
doch add apt repo jawoll also perform perform bevor dem clone machen wir das add note 14
repo so und was hatten wir da so und ist es so aus braucht kein mensch das da brauche
wir machen es mal ein bisschen größer das fenster ja nice sehr gut sehr gut also sprich
jetzt sollte das repo hinzufügen und jetzt muss ich note noch installieren also ab nee
nee nee install note 14 update cache yes sollte man vielleicht hinten dran machen dass es
dann auch funktioniert upgrade brauchen wir nicht ist ja gut so und da wollen wir jetzt
einfach nur note js installieren so jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
ich würde es jetzt ich würde es jetzt noch mal aus und schauen wir mal ob das jetzt oft
ob er das jetzt auf dem h cloud server list ob er das jetzt auf dem server ausführt ansiebele
ich meine die base sachen hat er schon gemacht mal gucken ob der jetzt noch js drauf installiert
ja ich mag manche auch am liebsten so das hat er alles schon gemacht deswegen geht das
jetzt schnell ok schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funst mit note plus rng das gibt es ja nicht
mehr alter twitch ihr könnt ja nicht laufen die ganzen emotes entfernen wo man sich schon
so dran gewöhnt hat kein pochem kein plus rng mir ist es ehrlich gesagt persönlich vollkommen
egal was es mit den leuten auf sich hat ich mag das emote das ist der aktuelle pochem
ok den markt das gefällt dem sebaro bestimmt der aktuelle pochem keine blind speedruns
mehr stimmt habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht ja das ok das kann ich auch mich würde echt
mal interessieren ob jemand der blind ist da wirklich offended war oh fuck dass es blind
speedruns gibt keck wait oh nee jetzt muss ich noch keys importieren ok wir machen das
anders leute wir machen das anders wir machen das anders ich hab's mir ich hab's mir anders
überlegt wir können einfach nur command in war schelmer ansible schell dann weiß ich
aber nicht wie es weitergeht ansible schell ansible kann den key adden ja ich weiß aber
den key nicht und falls er sich ändert ich wir können das jetzt einfach rein und gut
ist einfach so hinten ausführen ok das ist easy schell und dann einfach das hier so hinten
dran oder wie ok probier mal aus ob es funktioniert ok mal schauen schauen ob das jetzt klappt
es wird gekurlt gekurlt danach wird nordjs installiert ok also wenn das klappt dann wird
das auf was ansible nerv nicht rum mach einfach was soll ich machen warn warn falls ok manchmal
ist die beschreibung nicht so nicht so geil viel besser so und jetzt und jetzt hab ich
jetzt hab ich jetzt ein node drauf ich hab ne node poggers ich hab ne node drauf nice
sehr gut so und jetzt geht nämlich auch das street merchant würde ich sagen können wir
das ausprobieren npm install muss man glaube ich einmal machen und dann npm run start wenn
ich so richtig im kopf hab ok den npm install kann ich da gleich hinterher hinterher schicken
noch mal mit einem shell ark es gab doch noch change dir change dir gab's doch auch noch
change dir oh das ist nice also change dir zu root root street ich kann das richtig
schreiben ich copy paste das lieber bevor ich mich da verschreibe monka corona wupp c leute
wir haben extra emot dafür jetzt falls euch nicht aufgefallen ist vom chain lore wupp
c ok das hat funktioniert also was für npm install muss man machen ich führe es noch
mal aus ob es jetzt funktioniert haben hosten haben eigentlich längen beschränkung ja
mit sicherheit ich weiß aber nicht was es ist wahrscheinlich entweder 32 64 oder 128
oder sowas die stehen ja auf gerade zahlen cool ja das passt doch das ist doch mal mega
nice oh ich hab noch was vergessen leute das wichtigste dass das ganze noch kommunizieren
kann ich muss noch ich muss noch ein private network ernten dass die dass der eine server
überhaupt zum anderen hinkommt local 122 168 0.0 slash 24 so der klassiker und jetzt
wo ich noch gucken wie man den server attached beim erstellen create help help dir irgendwas
von network hier network vermute mal dass ich dort sagen kann das macht das testen wir
jetzt einfach direkt hier drin vermute mal dass ich da noch sowas sagen kann wie minus
minus network gleich oh minus minus network gleich local habe ich es genannt ja genau
passt das nämlich auch dass das der server also wie gesagt ich habe es ja ich habe es
ja vorhin aufgemalt im wim das ist ja so das frontend und die drei worker server die hängen
zusammen im privaten netz und das muss ich natürlich dran hängen attach to network node
eins net warum muss ich attach to network node achso das ist wenn ich es nachträglich
machen will ne ich kann es ja beim erstellen angeben dann ist es doch eigentlich besser
der chat ist heute richtig massive brain wieder ja ok so und nun von der idee her passt das
doch alles so oder oder habe ich jetzt irgendwas vergessen der sollte jetzt wirklich äh by
the way hat einer eine ahnung was passiert wenn ich mit n simple was blockendes starte
kann n simple was im background starten na gut ich kann einfach die shell command so angeben
dass er was im background startet ich muss ja noch npm start machen ok gucken wir mal
npm insofern npm run start das sollte jetzt einfach nur starten mit default konfig dass
ich weiß das funktioniert der name vom letzten n simple punkt ist noch falsch echt ach hier
äh äh moment wow fuck geht nicht failed oh fuck oder fehlen libraries da fehlen libraries
das sprint planning haben wir am anfang gemacht wir haben auch alle im kreis für einen scrum
gestanden haben unser kann man borthin und her geschoben wiki street merchant die hatten
nämlich die dependencies drinstehen im wiki das weiß ich noch das hat mich das letzte
mal auch verwirrt das haben wir nämlich schon mal gesehen 17 monate massive subs hier poggers
das ist ja richtig so debian based sorry sorry leute debian based wir sind ja die coolen
leute was die aussprache angeht so und das sind die dependencies die ich brauche fuck da
muss ich noch mal n riesen install dann testen wir doch gleich mal ob das install hier drüber
funktioniert install install das machen wir gleich da oben install dependencies und das
brauche ich was alles ok da muss man mein terminal groß mein editor groß what the fuck
na gut es ist es ist eine node.js anwendung da ist es eigentlich normal das ist quasi
best practice dass man das halbe internet mit installiert erst mal das halbe internet
als dependencies und dann noch mal das halbe internet als npm packages lip gtk alter was
will er denn das braucht er für ein chrome das braucht er das braucht er 100 pro für
ein chrome das ganze zeug hier das das braucht er bestimmt nicht für sein node das braucht
er das braucht er für ein chrome das der läuft siehst du wenn wir jetzt den wim hätten wir
das viel stylischer machen können mit den mit den kommers ok ich hätte ja auch ein
search and replace machen können aber weget das ist doch bestimmt schon drauf ok dann
schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert da sollte die dependencies installieren der
macht den npm install hier hinten dran ok ich führ das jetzt noch mal aus und dann
schauen wir mal ob das ding startet an sich was control plus rechts ah cool also das wusste
ich noch gar nicht also hätte ich quasi sowas machen können ne hätte ich nicht machen
können das ist für chrome ja das ist halt der vorteil wenn sie im container laufen lässt
aber bevor ich da jetzt noch docker konfig mit machen muss da ist glaube ich immer noch
einfacher so direkt laufen zu lassen ok so jetzt schauen wir mal ob das wenigsten starten
würde start eine runde postchampen chat ha funst ah das sind das sind browser settings
das kenne ich das doch es funktioniert da habe ich das musste ich in meiner konfig
machen genau das wusste man machen dann geht's das muss ich aber nicht im ansatz machen
weil ich habe ja schon eine fertige konflikt für dieses ding kennerkenn drei monat dankeschön
für den sub nice es funktioniert leute sehr gut sehr gut exzellent so ansible execute
command irgendwie essen oder background oder sowas background geht das
akul das alles gleich dabei schreibt genau das genau das hätte ich jetzt genau das in
der richtung hätte ich jetzt gesucht start simpel ja cool ja nice dann dann lassen wir
es doch mal abschließend laufen dann lassen wir es doch mal laufen die sache ok also ich
lasse jetzt mal abschließend das kripp laufen wir gucken mal funktioniert damit ich jetzt
sehe dass es auch wirklich funktioniert muss ich erst einmal noch zwei fake server erstellen
dass er die danach wieder löschen kann die heißen noch falsch aber das können wir gleich
fixen weiß doch egal ob ich die richtig ausweite oder nicht wieso kein system d ja wir können
auch unit file anlegen hast du eigentlich recht so wirka 2 und wirka 3 so und jetzt sollte
uns das kripp also von der ideen was das kripp jetzt machen sollte man das alles richtig
funktioniert list der sollte jeweils drei neue server erstellen die mit ansible richtig
konfigurieren und danach die alten server wieder löschen deine mein zu blackberry habe
ich null verfolgt was da gerade börsenmäßig abgeht ich weiß nur dass irgendwas abgeht
ok porsche mal gucken ob das funktioniert rebuild creating server location eins gucken
wir mal zu machte auch machte auch neuer wirka eins wird erstellt don't cry so much danke
für den für den sub falls ich nicht schon gesehen habe IQ plus plus auf jeden fall
wieder guck mal wie nice unser timeout auf server warten funktioniert das ist ja richtig
cool ach so die smartphones an sich ja kein schimmer wusste gar nicht dass leute gibt
noch blackberry smartphones haben oh was kein moment ich habe das noch aus kommentiert
leute ich kann nur ich habe das wichtigste noch aus kommentiert lull ich habe das update
aus kommentiert not like this aber zumindest das server rotaten sollte funktionieren guck
den ersten hat er gelöscht jetzt macht er den zweiten jetzt macht er den dritten fällt
noch mal wobei jetzt fällt er nicht beim dritten fällt er nicht ich kommentiere es noch mal
schnell aus ich will dass er fehlt es geht schneller warum tell net weil tell net gut
ist um offene ports zu checken und wenn es na ttp ist kann man auch schnell den gett machen
und sieht ob das richtig ist ok es ist gefällt jetzt machen wir das ganze noch mal aber prinzipiell
hat es funktioniert sieht man wir haben alle server rolling geup graded was es gab in neu
erstellt nice ok rebuild noch mal jetzt sollte es aber funktionieren ich sehe schon wir werden
heute nicht ganz fertig glaube ich wie oft willst du das rolling dann machen
ich
habe ja alles runtergestellt ich sollte jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr geploggt werden ich
will den ja auch irgendwie keine keine irgendwie nicht großartig laut verursachen oder sowas
aber falls ich eine neue ip brauche dann kann ich einfach die config für den street merchant
anpassen dann stelle ich einfach dass das noch ein bisschen weiter runter dass es nicht
unter die limits fällt und dann mache ich rebuild und ich habe gleich neue ip und ich
sehe gleich ob es funktioniert die werden denn die shops auf die werke aufgeteilt na
es gibt jetzt so wie ich sehe zwei möglichkeiten entweder ich mache eine config datei für
jeden der drei notes und kopier die dahin und oder ich mache ein template heute schon
game stop gepreist ne was macht denn was macht denn der game stop kurs der post schämt
der paint paint schämt ich finde es ja witzig wie sehr sich da jetzt die ganzen stonks leute
drüber aufregen so nach dem motto es wäre ein banden was hat jemand letztens erzählt
ein banden mäßiger eine banden mäßige markt manipulation wäre das jetzt gewesen
ja aber wenn sich irgendwelche big brain stonks typen im puff treffen und sachen absprechen
dann ist es das natürlich nicht klar oder logisch wer hätte das nicht denken können
vor allem banden mäßig nur weil ebenso tut man was auf reddit gelesen hatten das nach
macht aber guck mal jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren der hat sein ab upgrade gemacht ok wir sehen
auch gleich wie lang es dauert wir sehen auch gleich wie lang es dauert also ich hoffe
dass der so in fünf minuten durch ist mit dem ganzen kram
genau stripes so sieht es aus die suche nach aktuellen grafikkarten preisen cpu preisen
aber wie gesagt ich habe es so niedrig gestellt dass wenn ich daheim die seite bei amazon
mal ab und zu refresche dass fast mehr ist wie da
deswegen ich wurde jetzt ja auch schon letzten tagen hat seitdem ich die limits ein bisschen
runtergepasst hat nirgendswo mehr gebannt
ich bin nicht von docker weg für den preis camp also aktuell läuft das läuft der preis
camp selber noch im docker container ich muss es aber halt aufteilen auf mehrere back end
server das ist billiger und funktioniert besser und ich habe es jetzt ohne docker laufen weil
ich den eintrag habe das funktioniert in dem fall hier jetzt deutlich einfacher eine note
installieren das repo klonen und starten und fertig ist
mächtig viel auffangen nur zum spaß na ja wieso du kannst auch benutzen guck mal preiscamp.org
kannst du dir angucken und notification schicken lassen wenn es neue grafikkarten gibt
aber ich verdiene damit nix muss ich doch mal sagen das einzige wo ich da was verdiene
ist wenn zufällig mal einer wasser mit amazon link verkauft und die 70 euro server kosten
auch mehr wobei damit reduziere ich ja auch die server kosten die kriege ich im leben
dann wieder rein die rtx preise werden sinken aber das wird
wahrscheinlich schon bis zum sommer dauern denke ich
und ich mein man erkennt allein schon daran dass es mega professionelle software projekt
ist ja das hat einen changelog und alles was ein changelog hat muss richtig massive hacker
man sein
wolltest du nicht auch noch adsense rein machen ja ich habe mir überlegt aber ich
lasse es erstmal und guck mal was es kostet das ist die 3bm also wenn das sich in grenzen
hält und wenn ich das jetzt umziehe von dem 16 core auf die auf die einzelnen dann kostet
nur noch die hälfte und dann kann ich das eigentlich auch erstmal so bezahlen da brauche
ich kein adsense weil mir persönlich gehen auch werbung seiten mit werbung auf den sack
aber wenn das doch zu viel kostet dann mache ich vielleicht adsense rein keine ahnung das
ist aber nicht mal so dass ich wobei mal ganz ehrlich ich hatte jetzt glaub 25.000 views
auf der seite die letzten zwei tage also so wenig ist das gar nicht mehr als zwitzigerweise
mehr als 95 prozent der domains von meinem arbeitgeber zusammen hat der preisschamp im
monat wir haben da teilweise domains das gucken sich zwei leute im im jahr gefühlt an
ne chillfreak das kann nicht passieren weil die locations unterschiedlich sind und unterschiedliche
locations haben unterschiedliche ips wir haben 8.000 domains leute ungefähr da wo ich arbeite
8.000 domains und das sind domains dabei da greifste die echt am kopf wer sich das registriert
hat ja ich sag euch mal ein beispiel aber ich denke also ich denke mir ein beispiel aus
bringt euch nichts wenn ihr danach sucht die ähnlich zu diesem zu diesem wir haben domains
so in dieser richtung was weiß ich was was kann ich jetzt mal als beispiel bringen erspare
dir dann traumhaus.de oder sowas in der richtung das habe ich mir jetzt ausgedacht aber so
domains in dieser richtung haben wir erspare dir dann tolles traumhaus.de und sowas alter
wenn sich die dinger registriert hat die wollen übrigens jetzt sogar eine eigene top
level domain haben
also stellt euch vor als wäre die commerce bank oder so gibt es ist es nicht aber die
wollen dann top level domain punkt commerce bank wollen die sich jetzt holen ist das nicht
ultra teuer who cares die leute haben geld ja die wollen eine tld haben dann kriegen
die auch die haben genug geld die typen die registrieren alles was nicht bei drei auf
den bäumen ist wenn man genug geld hat
und ich würde sagen es funktioniert alles ich bin begeistert
wie teuer ist das circa ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
aber ist das nicht nice guck mal der macht jetzt einen rolling server rebuild inklusive
setup von dem system das einzige was ich jetzt noch machen muss ist gucken wie ich dies
müssen wir aber morgen machen das wird heute zu eng wie ich die richtige config für den
jeweiligen node drauf bekomme und dass ich das ganze im hintergrund starte so und starten
mache ich entweder mit einem unit file oder nohub starten gut ist
das gefällt mir echt gut guck jetzt ist er grad beim bilden einer ist noch da der hat
wirken eins wirken zwei hat er fertig drei ist er grad dabei und die existieren kurzer
zeit mal parallel aber das sind nur ein paar minuten was was heißt ich bezahle keine ahnung
fünf cent extra das macht nichts und dafür ist die downtime gering ich kriege auf jeden
fall eine neue ip die downtime ist gering also genau das was man haben will
den punkt habe ich vergessen habe ich am anfang gesagt habe ich auch wieder verdrängt
neue ip geringe downtime und ich weiß nicht irgendwas war noch warum ich das machen wollte
gut cpu last verteilen klar das ding brauche bis ich cpu last mal gucken wie lange das
script jetzt braucht dafür was passiert wenn du bei hetson das traffic limit exceedest wird
automatisch nachgekauft keine ahnung habe ich nur nie geschafft zumal die 20 terabyte
ja auch nur outgoing sind also ich glaube auch nicht dass ich das hinkriege nice leute
alle server da poggers ich muss sagen das ist richtig cloud native hyper poggers also
traffic pack ich im leben nicht leute das finde ich echt cool dass das so gut geht sehr
nice so und jetzt gehen wir mal list gucken wir mal server root add haben wir hier den
da haben wir keine worker 3 tmax drauf street merchant drauf und npm run start also geht
auch bloß der browser geht nicht weil die config datei noch nicht drauf ist martin
13 monate hyper subscription hier für die 18 monate subscription hier funst perfekt das
ist mal agile auf knopfdruck komplette infrastruktur neu gebaut so muss das sein exquisite so und
wenn ich nicht arm werde lösche ich die server jetzt wieder server delete kann man da mehrere
sachen hintereinander machen vielleicht mit kommer ne ok so servers ne ok da muss man
die einzeln löschen jetzt aber delete bämm bämm bämm leute es ist jetzt 22 ich muss
jetzt gleich ins bett aber ich würde sagen wir machen das morgen fertig weil mein ziel
ist dass ich ich möchte die worker rebuilding können auf einen schlag wenn zwar notwendig
ist und nämlich mit terraform funktioniert das nicht so gut ich habe es mir auch überlegt
ob ich mit terraform machen sollte aber gerade dieses rolling upgrade und so ich glaube das
ist nichts was man gut mit terraform skripten das ganze nix großartig skripten also nix
nix die logik gut einbauen kann so und deswegen macht also mein ziel ist dass ich den dass
ich das price jam frontend und die und die werker server mit knopfdruck quasi hinstellen kann
die werker server gehen ja schon und dass ich dann nur noch quasi einmal auf deployen
drücken muss so und was wir uns vielleicht sonst noch überlegen könnten ist dass die
werker server das github repo regelmäßig pullen da mache ich doch da mache ich doch
ein docker compose file weil dann kann ich regelmäßig checken ob es updates vom repo
gibt und die werker restarten lassen übrigens leise rgb keksner wie würdest du empfehlen
die dort falls in ein git repo zu bekommen alles übers sim links und dann soft oder hartlings
nee ich würde empfehlen du nimmst das was ich auch nehme dafür fack wie heißt jadam
jadam nimmst du jadam das da das da github jadam das macht das für dich
das ist quasi den git rapper der für dich sim link
eine lösung ist einfach pock ja ich hoffe dass sie auch wirklich pock funktioniert ja
jetzt also von der idee kann ich das jetzt einfach so machen ich so also sollte ich probleme
haben mit den werker server dann mache ich einfach nicht ab dann mache ich einfach hier
einen rebuild dann ist wieder da und das frontend aufbauen werde ich folgendermaßen machen
da mache ich noch ein zusätzliches ansible script ich bei der way ich sollte das nicht
base nennen ich nenne das werker jammel rebuild ansible werker jammel genau da mache ich noch
ein frontend jammel ansible und das mache ich auch so dass das alles komplett installiert
das haben wir letztens im stream schon gemacht und dann muss ich einfach nur noch die anwendung
drauf pushen und gut ist ich habe mir auch überlegt dass ich den breitschirm aktuell
mache ich das ja alles mit ich habe einen docker compose file und ich push das repo und
ich habe einen git hook der quasi das compose file jedes mal neu startet funktioniert ganz
gut aber in dem fall also in meinem anwendungsfall ist es glaube ich komplett ohne container
wirklich am einfachsten ich mache ich mache das frontend per ansible fertig da kommt ein
webserver drauf und ich werde einfach die vue js anwendung lokal bilden pscp in das
web root verzeichnis vom webserver schieben und auch das dotnet program lokal bilden und
per scp auf den server schieben und dann einfach starten das ist glaube ich sogar einfacher
als irgendwelche container action zu machen in dem fall da brauche ich keine private container
registry für oder irgendwie großartige magic einfach lokal comiten und einen deploy script
starten was zwei dinger baut und scp oder ersyncht das ist in dem fall glaube ich die
mit abstand einfachste variante und dann hinterher in ein system zcl restart schicken für die
jeweiligen services man muss es nicht immer vercontainerisieren wie gesagt aktuell habe
ich vercontainerisiert und ich glaube dass das in diesem simplen anwendungsfall ohne ganz
ohne container tatsächlich die einfachste variante ist da kann der webserver auf direkt
das ganze html ausliefern und reverse box hin zu der dotnet anwendung glaube das funktioniert
am besten jetzt werden wir dann sehen aktuell läuft der preisschamp auf container action
da ist er ich habe schon gedacht er wäre kaputt leute ich habe schon gedacht er wäre kaputt
aber ist er ist er ist er nicht ist er nicht kaputt er ist am start excellent oh den 5800
haben wir gerade ganz schön viele guckt mal hier fast leute guckt mal hier fast uvp preis
aber das ist der 8000 das ist der 5800 schon immer war der 5800 nicht die cpu die eigentlich
irgendwie voll sinnlos war weil sich alle in den 5900 kaufen oder den kleinen zeigt
zu hohe preise an ne minefactory 448 448 zeigt überhaupt nicht zu hohe preise ans vollkommen
richtig was da drin steht alternate 479 passt doch genau das was da steht das ist nicht
unter uvp uvp ist 449 oder die haben es angepasst kann auch sein ja ist übelst teuer ja gut
das liegt daran minefactory ist tatsächlich unter uvp aber das hier ist ja der durchschnittspreis
über alle shops weil es ja auch eine history ist wo du gucken kannst wie war es wie teuer
war es denn so im durchschnitt dann passt das natürlich so jetzt nicht wenn das auf
den einen tag jetzt auf den einen shop aktuell guckst dafür gibt es das hier unten ja aber
vielleicht bewegen wir uns wieder ein halbwegs gescheite preis regionen ja pp hans so alles
klar heute wir sehen uns ich gehe ins bett bis morgen macht's gut zu